[Musique]
vous arrivez là où les questions par
exemple des ateliers de gymnastique
douce mais qu'on imagine plus facilement
avec des personnages et c'est vrai que
la boxe c'est pas quelque chose qu'on
avait fourré au départ mon bac
la marche des activités gymnastique
douce des choses comme ça mais ça cette
activité c'est nouveau et ça va affecter
vos proches on tend les bras devant et
on fait des petits bals pompe peut aller
doucement
voilà allez vous fait qu'on vous pouvez
voler alors ça ne vole pas dans la lah
droit au logement pour les moindres à
paris à la corse
bien que je suis en tiff principal
c'était effectivement de leur faire une
activité qui n'étaient pas connus qu'ils
pouvaient aussi apporter certaines
notions d' équilibre de sur l'activité
physique mais aussi sur la gestion des
émotions la gestion de l'impossibilité
c'est pas toujours évident pour des
personnes qui ont des troubles cognitifs
deux parfaits et en voilà le bilan est
très positif ici ils ont fait ça avec
beaucoup de plaisir
et à tout âge de 75 à 95 ans aux modos
donc commandes a participé vraiment
avec plaisir mais attention super
qu'est-ce qu'on fait un peu on se salue
merci pas au sérieux le voir